bismillah alhamdulillah assalamualaikum
that is the greeting by now you know if
you've been watching a Deen show that's
the greeting of peace peace be unto you
and my next guest is very very exciting
very exciting to have these special
people on the Deen show telling us their
story on how they stay afloat how they
stay on top rather than going below so
my next guest is going to clarify how
being a young man in today's society
everything is calling one to corruption
and evil how he's managed to be doing
good how he managed to be doing Islam
which simply means to acquire peace by
submitting to the owner of peace the one
guy when we come back
bono here on the Dean show don't go
nowhere there's only one word is His
Messenger
ha there's only one bad and Jesus was
his messenger no I did that maybe it
maybe it's just to break the ice
Salaam alaikum Bono yeah so how you
doing my man on the Deen show so do you
now wrap or you flow or you get poetic
cuz that's how do people know you yeah I
mean you know it's funny enough they all
come from the same family right I
consider myself a storyteller stories of
whether it's you know through hip-hop or
through spoken word the medium remains
the same it's really just writing it's
storytelling which you know has a long
tradition in Islam as well if we think
of a lost power of Allah and the Quran
and the way in which I lost count I was
revealed many of the stories of the
prophets right
beautiful beautiful view of the best of
stories so for many of us you know
layman's people who take up writing as a
craft you know I think if we have an
example before in there now tell us
we're gonna pause right there just Paul
go in or reverse because you're flowing
can I say flowing sure you're flowing
you're talking you're poetic about some
good stuff
not bad stuff anyone who hears your
lyrics they'll get enticed to God
willing to do good inshallah but how
were you always doing good where you're
always because you're young and there's
a lot of pressure out there peer
pressure it's not cool
with us we know it's cool to do it's
like it's cool to be a Muslim but now in
today's society you got to be cursing
rapping about degrading women rapping
about bling-bling and all these other
things that a lot of it is just wasting
time how did you make a transformation
talk to us well you know what I I can
say that I am heavily influenced by the
hip-hop culture of North America I grew
up listening to music used to yeah right
right so and in my you know my own
jahiliyyah times I used to I used to rap
yeah so I used to be involved in hip-hop
and you know now a lot of people really
know this about me but I was you know I
was part of a band and I was doing
fairly well I was actually opening up
for some pretty big acts and you know
funny story I found myself when I
started trying to practice my Deen and
trying to combine these two lifestyles I
found myself at a club one night
you know it was time for Isha and but
we're about to go on I'm thinking you
know what am I gonna pray I'm looking
around the space I'm like where's the
best place for me to pray is what am I
doing here so ho ho ho let's back it up
for the night yet Muslims out there who
you mentioned Aisha which is one of the
prayers of Islam and that's one of the
pillars the first one obviously to bring
you up to speed is how one becomes a
Muslim is that that person declares
there's no god but God and Muhammad is
the messenger and that will also include
all the preceding messengers Jesus Moses
Abraham and all of them and you just you
learn so much already
so now when one accepts Islam acquires
peace by submitting it to the owner
peace the one God you start to establish
the prayer what you're doing in the club
brother
great question what you doing in the
head what are you looking for a place to
you know what you gonna make a Jamaat
with the ladies everybody a club and 50
cents and what's going on okay so this
is what I found myself in the
predicament I was like you know what if
I can't be in a place where I could pray
and if I'm not in a place where I feel
comfortable enough to pray that I
shouldn't be here anyways and I think
for a lot of young people we have to ask
ourselves those questions you know for
many of us we constantly are you know
trying to compromise or come to some
sort of balance but oftentimes our Deen
ends up suffering more why it's very
easy for us to be like Oh a lot of the
most merciful allies you know it's okay
and subhanAllah you know you shouldn't
reflect on the mercy of Allah before he
commits a sin it's like you're almost
neglecting the fact that you still might
be punished for it and so it was a scary
predicament that I came to was a scary
place where I was at where I was like
you know what if I can't pray here if
it's not a place where I feel like I can
be a Muslim then I probably shouldn't be
here to begin with let's back it up just
a little bit more but before you even
came because we're living in the real
world there's a lot of temptation out
there it's tantalizing but now how did
you even come to the point where some
people aren't even thinking about the
Creator that happens on earth to stop no
matter where they're at to pray how did
you even come to the realization that
Islam is the truth that it provides the
proof that it's logical rational
scientific everything points that this
is not man-made but it's from the
creator of the heavens and earth how did
you realize that well you know I grew up
in a Muslim household how many I had
parents and I kind of did the ritual
things you would do in a Muslim
household you would you know go to
Islamic school on Saturdays and Sundays
and you know you'd do the things and go
to eat prayer and all the things that
you're supposed to do but I never really
had an understanding for it myself like
a lot of Muslim people you need my love
in Muslim household a lot many don't
it's just a cultural thing that we do so
at a certain age because it wasn't a
real attachment I didn't really
understand it was very easy for me to
let it go so at a certain age I found
myself you know I was on the religion of
my friends which was you know literally
you know basketball or you know parties
and you know all the things that come
with that kind of like typical high
wasting time wasting time right but
that's what my friends are doing so I
wouldn't follow them I would be a part
of them and so I really kind of found
myself caught up in just chasing this
world and I'm chasing the fun and
glamour of what this world can offer us
and it wasn't until I really took some
time to do some real reflecting on my
own without my parents forcing me
without anybody telling me look this is
what you should do you know it really
took me to a place of humility when I
could stop and think wow you know look
at all the things that I have look at
all the things that you know I've been
given and Who am I to not at least give
things you know Who am I to not pay
respects to the one who's blessed me
with so much and so it was a lot of that
it was a lot of constant back and forth
and you know one thing at a time I would
stop doing this I would try picking this
up it was a very long process you know
I'm still a work in progress by any
means almost all of us definitely I'm
not you know saved by any means I'm
still like I would joke about earlier
I'm floating I'm barely floating so I
walk people as a flow I mean so because
of that you know like I said it was a
slow process it was a step-by-step
process it was you know maybe you know
not hanging out with these friends
anymore
maybe meeting some new people you know
and I tell people this all the time if
your friends aren't gonna empower you
make you better than they you should
really question if they're your real
friends are not you know a lot of us for
young people were heavily influenced by
our friends and if you're not picking
the right friends it can really be
detrimental to your own health and your
well-being now did you have an
experience because some people they like
you know I had a dream or something just
came about you did you have you know
because Islam is something logical
rational if you take an analytic
scientific approach it's a thinking
man's decision that you made
you follow your heart what did you have
to do did you have this dream experience
or something more what happened like in
your life that really had you pick up
the Quran the verbatim Word of God do
their homework where you're researching
you know a lot of people have that
life-changing experience that one-off
incident I didn't necessarily have that
for me it was a kind of sequence of
smaller minor events it was a matter of
me you know constantly building on like
wow why did this happen wow this
happened you know and it almost taking
me to a place of self-reflection I think
when we're alone when we're not
surrounded by you know the the
consumption of wealth or the you know
pursuit of stupidness as I like to call
it right and you really take time to
reflect like really take time alone and
just think about this world think about
everything we are about think about who
you are where you came from it's a
natural conclusion you know you come to
the conclusion of one God and then once
you're there then it's based on you know
I have the deal I had a little
understanding of Islam and so for me it
was I was able to build on that you know
and I would start reading I would start
watching stuff like a Dean show online
which is how law is a very big influence
to me you'd be surprised so you know for
a lot of us who you know we take things
step and it's one step at a time and so
you know getting closer and closer and
feeling like wow you know feeling people
I can relate to like yeah this guy's not
gonna judge me he's not gonna tell me
I'm this tell me I'm that he understands
my experiences finding people like that
reached me out to them being inspired by
many of the shoe even Sheikh Saeed who
is you know speaker today who was a big
big influence to me in my life any
probably doesn't even know it and you
know it's these little little little
instances that have really helped carve
who I am today
come to you come to the law praises to
the Creator heavens and earth and we'll
be right back with more on a diesel okay
you've got your dream home and you've
got your dream car but you're gonna get
old and things are going to happen to
you in your life and then what have you
got at the end of the day is an empty
dream that has no real foundation we are
gonna die and we're gonna meet our Lord
and He is going to judge us it becomes
an obligation for each single human
being to find out what the Quran is
Islam is telling us to stay away from
things which are bad for your person and
bad for the society
back here with boner on the Dean show
and we left off with now reflecting
wanting to know the purpose of life its
natural isn't it you want to know why
you're here
so now do you know the purpose of life
is it clear and honey that's very clear
now again no matter the good amount of
the bad you know in any circumstance we
still get praise to Allah and this for
me was a true eye-opening experience
right for me to really reflect on my
life and say you know what all this bad
has happened to me all this good as
happen to you but do everything through
the good what may seem as bad I'm still
able to say thank you all praises to my
lord to a lost man without to Allah who
has blessed me with so much and again
and people some people who watch the
show say Eddie we got it already but
look I'm just trying to keep it steady
because there are a lot of people who
tuned in for the first time the Muslim
got has not yet Muslim neighbor to watch
it they hear these Arabic terms we have
to define them and you said Allah and
someone said that some moon god what do
you got a second
is that God a lot is you know the name
of our only Lord the only worthy the
only being worthy of worship in all of
existence the first the last eternal the
ever being he is our Lord our Creator
our sustainer the one who grants us all
the bounties we have and the one who
ultimately we will return to that's the
one guy one creator of all what a
creative not creative he's the creator
where his creation just worship the
create tour that's the simple message
you realize that you said before we went
to break the one God
now that you're looking at all to the
other judaism christianity hinduism
buddhism did you ill reflect just to try
to sniff to see maybe if that's yeah i
thought you know what i didn't really i
mean to say in my initial stages but i
was very familiar with these religions
just by virtue of being in a very
multicultural community and already
doing a bit of research on my own here
and there and having friends who I would
speak to but nothing ever made sense to
me except one God even in my times of
complete you know disobedience to a lot
I'd still understood that this was the
only being worthy of worship it never
occurred to me that there could be two
or three or four or five doesn't make
sense logically you know I'm not people
ask me if I'm religious I'm not
religious I'm rational you know yeah
it's like come on use your head that's
what it really comes down to so I mean
even in my worst of phases they would
never occurred to me that there could be
some sort of disruption in the heavens
you know that a loss Allah with the one
Lord was the creator and sustainer of
all this is what I understood just from
my own ignorance just out of my own love
and compassion for myself God being a
man what about this I think for a lot of
those they remind me of like Harry
Potter books or something like that
there's these amazing fables but you
know when you logically think about it
there's holes and a lot of those you
know those stories and plots and you
know it's unfortunate that many people
because I do some Street Dowell I try to
educate people on Islam on the street
corners and for a lot of people you know
when you stop to think and you stop and
telling me look think we're actually
what makes more sense you know for them
it's like all it's not supposed to make
sense religion is this what are you just
following you know why don't you just
pick up a newspaper and fall or whatever
it tells you to do then so you know it's
unfortunate many people are kind of so
skewed in their ways and they say you
know for a lot of them you know how
could I become a Muslim it's not what my
parents did and it's find up because
this was the same thing that the the
Arabs during the time when the Prophet
peace be upon him used to say they say
how can we abandon our religion of our
forefathers well this is what they did
how can we now take this new thing up
and people today say the same thing so
it's a very interesting parallel but at
the same time very sad just blindly
following what their forefathers did
their parents not questioning just going
along with the ride whatever happens
they're not thinking about the purpose
of life why they're here and you
mentioned something about just think
just be rational and then they say it's
not supposed to make sense but you
and go to a map class or English class
and it's not making sense you don't ask
questions
yeah you definitely walk out of there
but for many of us you know when you
know the issue of religion or God comes
up it's a very touchy subject for a lot
of people and for them they don't feel
as though a they have the authority to
speak on it because for a lot of people
they've been taught that you know this
is the priest the preacher this is the
order and rank he knows everything you
know nothing you know he has a
connection with God you don't you speak
to him he'll speak to God and bring back
the message what your sign is totally
against right I have my own connection
with a lot you have your own connection
with Allah we are all created by Allah
thus we should have a connection with
Allah there's no higher there's no one
who I would speak to to speak to Allah
he doesn't need any interest seaters he
doesn't need any translators he doesn't
need anyone to convey the message for
him I can speak to a lot just by raising
my hands and so the beauty of that is
that I've come to you know establish my
own connection with my Lord and when I
do something wrong when I do something
right when something good happens and
something bad happens to me I say hey
you know this is to Elisha shall return
this is who created me in this to
ultimately I will come back to that is
just so rational logical what you're
saying and God doesn't eat he doesn't
sleep he doesn't do the things that
human beings do and we're just wanting
to worship God directly alone and not
the things that he created now do some
people say you know what being active in
Dawa trying because sharing is caring
and we care for our brothers in humanity
who we want to be our brothers in faith
so we want to share invite them and call
them to think about what's the purpose
of like why are you here you're gonna
you live you die and their drama in
between right so what is it you just get
your belly full make some money
right in in a nice Bentley and announce
Rolls Royce or not even that maybe just
ride your bike and then you die it's so
funny in it it's really sad and you know
what I had somebody told me a very funny
analogy where they said if you were
going to an airport and you were stuck
overnight and for some reason another
you would missed your flight and you
have to stay at the airport what would
you buy maybe you'd buy like a
toothbrush maybe you'd buy a bag of
chips you'd buy a small amount of things
just to get by
now imagine in this world we are simply
travelers we came from somewhere we will
return somewhere this place is not the
final journey this is not the final home
but for many of us we get so caught up
in and it's like you're at the airport
buying 56 sandwiches and you're going
out here and you're buying this you're
getting massaged you're doing this
realizing that hey eventually you will
be going home this is this world this is
the dunya this life so for many of us we
forget that this is just a place the
Prophet SAW I sent him peace be upon him
describe this world as like a traveler
stopping for shade under a tree right
just you know just for a second we're
here and then we're gone
and so what a way to live our lives with
humility with honor understanding that
you know we were here for this moment
but eventually you know we're gonna go
and we just want to entice people to
excite people to if this is making sense
the more they dig into Islam the more
it's gonna make sense because everything
you need to know about who your Lord is
it's there in this verbatim word of god
the Quran purpose of life is there where
you're going when your diet is there and
how to live your life now that you've
acquired peace by submitting to the
owner of peace
doing God's will not your desires the
one God as we've said and we keep
stressing is because some people they
have been programmed on possibly adding
the wrong way so they go one plus one
plus one is one so and they can make
guided to a man into a woman into this
that and the other it gets confusing so
we say one God and now doing good deeds
do you feel that by doing this system of
Islam do you feel that it's developed
your character are you a better person
do you deal better with your family with
your mother father his friends and you
know it's so interesting I remember one
time a friend of mine we were getting on
the bus and at the bus station and there
was nobody at the window you know but I
still put my money in and then somebody
was kind of like you know why would you
there's nobody there yeah I'm not
worried about him Allah is watching me
oh it's so for us we developed this code
this honor that is not for the show of
other people whether you're with me or
not I'm acting a certain way I'm doing
what it's right not to please you to
please my lord who has stole so many
bounties so much honor upon me giving me
the title allowed me to worship Him this
is a
on itself not many people can come to
this you know and I asked people you
know my friends who are not yet Muslim
just learn do yourself a favor
there's no harm in picking up a book you
know knowledge is power we learn about
this in school we learn about this in
every fraction of life why not when it
comes to religion why not when it comes
something that may actually be the key
to salvation for you for eternity you
know pick up a book read
do yourself a favor as a friend I'm
asking them as a friend pick up a book
please just do it you're not gonna lose
anything I promise you and if any good
comes from it it is from Allah and it's
very simple and do a comparative study
pick up the Bible pick up anything that
someone makes a claim that is from the
Creator along with the Quran with the
citizen here intention that you want to
get close to God but asking God to guide
you and do the work do the legwork yes
it's a simple process like you looking
for a car something anything you know
you're gonna be there analysis when
people go apartment shopping when they
go car shopping you didn't put it in
this 5060 hours of research yeah right
but when it comes to you know learning
about God it's kind of like oh my dad so
this is what's fine doesn't make sense
and there is no way if there's the right
way out there the way of the Creator and
you put all these different ideologies
philosophies that are man-made there's
no way that if you're sincere you cannot
find the one truth that's from God
Almighty it's you know it's a benefit to
yourself it's such a simple way of life
if anything I can describe it to my
friends that it makes life so much
easier
you know with relationships with friends
family even with a spouse right
everything is done the Prophet peace be
upon him left so much for us in every
aspect of our lives is clearly outlined
for us you can't go wrong you know
there's no gray area and where there is
gray area of home did he lab all praises
to Allah we have scholars we have people
who look interpret things for us so
you're not left to kind of you know your
own just whatever this guy says we do
know we can learn and research on our
own and create and develop our own
connection with God absolutely let's
take a break and we'll be right back for
more of this exciting episode on the
Dean shell peace I just want to say very
simple massive
all of the profits would have been
labeled Muslims because this essential
message with the same message and Jesus
affirming you said hero will Joe the
Lord your God is one God when you look
at the Bible says the earth has four
corners that's wrong
I mean the scientists were fighting it
and the church was throwing people into
prison how could I stand behind the
pulpit on Sunday morning and preach a
sermon that I knew was at variance with
the actual taproot of Christianity the
Bible there is not a single unambiguous
statement in the complete Bible where
Jesus Christ peace be upon him says say
that I am God always favored should be
one of the beautiful things about our
religion of Islam is the emphasis on
direct ritual and prayer to God directly
there is no intermediary
never complain there are no
superstitious rituals it's very simple
and very clear people often say to me
why have you become us I give a very
frivolous ounce and I say I wanted to be
on the side of the Angels the knowledge
decide to pull the final curtain down in
this place to Parker's of God he's the
number-one rap artist in the world he
sold over 60 million records well
millions Steve Miller not only was he a
successful musician he was a successful
actor he was a young guy where basically
everything that somebody you would think
that life is all about he had everything
you can imagine so I make him peace be
on to you back here on the Dean show
with our brother Bona now I want to just
get in a few more points questions
you mentioned the club and you mentioned
taking a time out having to pray I know
some other people who went through the
same phase because not overnight you
take the medicine it takes time to kick
in Islam you start doing it you might
have been the worst of the worst
drinking fornicating drugs being with
all these men all these women but Islam
changes you you have to implement it and
now that person could be at the club
could be anywhere but now they stop and
reflect like you did at that moment you
didn't give up the prayer that's the key
I know pray people that be at the after
our party and but they will stop to pray
eventually they never went back to the
after-party but it took some time
because the prayer will keep one away
from evilness but let's focus on this
prayer after you've acknowledged there's
no god but God and now you and Mohammed
is the last and final messenger peace be
upon him now you implement the the salat
how important and heavy this was to help
you to transform to be the best human
being the chicken it's it's a lifeline
it's you know if I can compare it we
generally eat three times a day but we
pray five times a day so this tells you
the importance we can go without food I
mean human can sustain without food for
quite a long time a couple days at least
but it's a lot prayer you can't go a
couple hours without it honestly
it's your connection it's your you know
your lifeline like for me it's something
where if
I have an internal clock now we're a
honky loud praise to Allah been praying
for a while and so for fudgie or for
early morning prayer you know I wake up
my body makes wakes me up it's difficult
for a lot of people at first when you
start praying it can be difficult
because it is you know you kind of but
you learn to station your life around it
everything your day revolves around your
prayer and eventually you know I would
almost become sick if I didn't pray like
I would develop this gut feeling like
literally physically I would feel ill if
I was missing a prayer if I was late for
it my body would tell me somethings
wrong you know you need you need
something like a drug addict when they
don't get their drugs they start
twitching right I don't pray I feel like
I'm missing something and so this is the
connection that you develop when you
start really you know having that
healthy lifeline between your Lord is
something you'll never go without and
this is what's helped you to develop
your character develop your relation by
developing a relationship with the one
God the Creator Allah this now you'll
see the change it's hard for you to sit
in between prayers it's hard for you to
do something dumb and then think I'm
gonna go pray in 10 minutes you know it
does develop your life in a format where
you know you you take time to reflect
every single day like I told you earlier
I took a time to reflect in my life
imagine I did that five times a day not
including the you know the obligee
sunnah prayers the optional prayers
afterwards right just for mandatory
prayers alone I would be stopping five
times a day to reflect and speak to my
lawyer now it on it's only fair and the
people and we're excited that they're
sitting and I'm sure they're excited
because they're learning so much we got
to give them a treat now we got to give
them a treat some people they've heard
you Flo Buster rhyme a rap you know and
it's not even with any band no musical
instruments nothing is just your
melodious voice right right so can you
give us a taste and give us the treat
now here on the Dean show give us a
short okay let me take a moment and show
some kindness to the folks that thought
blindness was a disease that affected
the eyes alone I promise I won't judge
you
I barely know how to love you and like
fools we preach rules but we don't even
follow our own everybody needs comfort
some people find it and this some people
find it in that and some
people just don't find it at all but
this world is full of signs from the
moons of the stars in the sky from the
bees and the bollocks like a seed in
your blood like a fiend with drug makes
you need to look up and question what's
up what you deal with the stuff when
your spirits of question you trek
through the rough for like thunder and
struck sick being it was all the size
that was sent they finally make sense
you feel the torment so you need to
repent when your heart is cement it's
hard as a brick cause your soul is worth
more than the dollars and cents all the
money in the world couldn't buy you
happiness because verily it is in the
remembrance of Allah that hearts don't
find rest God willed it and you were
here on the Deen show thank you for
being with us here may God Almighty
Allah rewards you thank you so much and
again thank you so much because you were
an inspiration to me as well and whether
you know it or not you really are and
you know what it starts with wanting it
you got a one if your bellies forward
for everything else then you know what
no matter how great the gourmet meal is
you're not going to eat you got to
realize that this life is short it's
gonna end soon wake up people and I'm
not going to tell you to just take my
word for it realize that people die
every day so form an investigation don't
just live from Friday to Friday don't
just live from one weekend to the next
try to attach yourself to something
that's permanent and that's the
Hereafter this life is short
don't be a loser at the end because
eventually you're going to lose this
life because you're going to die and
then if you invested all your time and
effort in this life you're also
definitely going to lose the next ask
the one who created you to guide you and
do a little bit of the legwork do a
little bit of the legwork like you
didn't legwork for everything else and
I'm telling you the truth
there the treasure is there the map is
there now you just gotta get up off your
back and get out there and visit us here
every week on the until next time peace
I love you I bow to you oh my oh my you
are my boy I bow to you
oh my oh my my my heart I bow to you oh
my you are you my lord I bow to you oh
my oh my you my lord
I bow to you